und dann ist diese woche auch noch
donald trump sagen wir mal
freigesprochen worden
der von den republikanern beherrschte us
senat sagt ihr präsident habe in der
ukraine affäre wähler seine macht
missbraucht noch den kongress behindert
also er natürlich beides gemacht habe
den republikanern ist es egal und führt
selbst war das mindestens der wichtigste
freispruch seit nelson mandela
mindestens meine damen - gestern hat er
bei seiner siegesfeier konferenz
jedenfalls noch mal ausgiebig
geschildert was man ihm in den letzten
wochen alles angetan hat und natürlich
gab es auch warme worte an den
politischen gegner hier wirklich kein
einfacher job für den phönix dolmetscher
es war bösartig es war korrupt waren
viele lügen im raum wir sind durch die
hölle gegangen in ganz unfairerweise was
wir durchgemacht haben es war eine
schande
wir sind unglaublich unfair behandelt
worden die demokraten sind lausige
politiker sie sind fies schlimme leute
wirklich niederträchtig das war
natürlich alles bullen scheiße totale
polen scheiße
[Applaus]
nach
effektiver weg
völlig korrekt übersetzt so ich fürchte
jetzt wo der präsident mit seiner bullen
scheiße durchgekommen ist gibt es für
den man gar keine grenzen mehr wirklich
die republikanische partei unterwirft
sich endgültig dem autokraten azubi hier
und wir lernen selbst eine so alte und
ehrwürdige verfassung wie die
amerikanische kann mit dem richtigen
mann im weißen haus ganz schnell zu
altpapier werden das ist so wie
unversöhnlich wie gespalten die usa
inzwischen sind konnte man diese woche
auch sehr schön beobachten ich weiß
nicht ob sie es gesehen haben trumps
rede zur lage der nation und zwar auf
kita niveau erst verweigert er der
parlamentspräsidentin pelosi den
handschlag und immer halt meine mappe
oma und als er fertig ist zeigt sie
durch subtile körpersprache gesehen
seine rede so fand und sie nimmt sich
dafür zeit leben noch
das nicht
und ja das ging sehr lange leider leider
hat oma nennt sie aber auch eigene
probleme ihre demokraten haben den
auftakt zum großen varia aber wirklich
komplett vergeigt in europa hat es
nämlich ewig gedauert bis der sieger der
demokraten verstand und zwar wegen einer
app die beim auszählen nicht richtig
funktioniert hat und es war echt lustig
zu sehen wie die kollegen von den us
sendern über dieses große nichts was da
in der vorbei nach passiert ist trotzdem
stunden lang berichten mussten so ein
spannendes kopf-an-kopf-rennen
sieger im duell war dann später und ganz
knapp vor bernie sanders ein mann namens
pete boutique oder so ja das ist der
bürgermeister von south bend indiana
gehört das ist so was wie das
amerikanische würselen
jedenfalls was für ihn möglicherweise
bedeutenden guter mann ist ein guter
mann der pid butt butt butt butt butt
butt butt butt butt
jetzt haben
so trug sich auszahlt
[Applaus]
und jetzt sage ich ihnen noch was diese
us-wahl am dritten november ist leider
jetzt schon entschieden haben hat es
geschafft seinen großen rivalen joe
biden somit dreck zu bewerfen das
idiotische weise was hängen geblieben
ist und alle anderen sind aus
verschiedenen gründen nicht mainstream
genug für die amerikaner ja sorry es ist
so am vierten november wird es heißen er
ist leider noch da ich fürchte dass die
demokraten haben keine chance also es
sei denn natürlich thomas kemmerich
tritt noch mal an
das ist klar
ja es ist wirklich so was soll ein beim
thema trump überhaupt noch hoffnung
machen zunächst einmal ganz menschlich
er ernährt sich nicht wirklich gesund
und er trainiert nicht und er ist 70 das
ist ganz schön alt und da kann einiges
passieren und man kann das alles
natürlich auch völlig anders sehen
achten sie bitte darauf in unseren
talkshows sitzen jetzt auch immer öfter
so deutsch amerikanische unternehmer die
sich als riesen tram fans outen einer
davon ist zum beispiel sebastian pufpaff
spreche ich das richtig aus naja fast
das heißt sebastian pufpaff bei der
familie stammt aus bad honnef texas oder
wie wir sagen aus page natürlich
sebastian pufpaff ist chef einer kleinen
mittelständischen landminen manufaktur
am niederrhein und hat sich daher riesig
gefreut über diese meldung präsident
trump hat den us streitkräften die
erlaubnis erteilt künftig wieder
landminen einzusetzen
trotz internationaler ächtung will
us-präsident trump die heimtückischen
waffen nun künftig wieder einsetzen und
zwar weltweit
und das natürlich weltweit ja die
bekloppte obama regierung hatte das auf
den einsatz in korea beschränkt max no
sense nein nein das problem ist doch
landminen haben ein wahnsinnig
schlechtes image die alltagstauglichkeit
wieder komplett vernachlässigt bürger
wir haben zum beispiel so einen totalen
nervigen drecks köder in der
nachbarschaft naja hatten die mal die
frage ist ja die
die frage war wie kann man unter den
umständen das hängt von donald trump
sein regime erwäge natürlich nardelli ja
man wird hier blind für die realität
wenn man wie sie an der
öffentlich-rechtlichen titel saugt aber
ich als unternehmer und höllische
attraktiver selfmade millionär
also muss ja geradezu trump fan sein
weil der mann alles zurückbringt was uns
leistungsträger behindert klimaschutz
umweltschutz fackelt menschenrechte so
hat dieses ganze schwule gedöns weg für
mich ist donald trump wie jesus nur
klüger
im grunde genommen lassen sie mich
weitergehen im grunde genommen eine
orangene anti greta ja er bringt uns
frieden also nicht in echten kriegen
aber in dem hier meine ministerien ist
puerto rico
[Musik]
da musste erst mal drauf kommen ist auch
super er wurde mitten in
naturschutzgebieten in alaska soll
endlich ohne ende so ein waldweg gefüllt
werden und in kalifornien gibt schramm
jetzt 400.000 hektar für fragen frei
denn wie sagt der volksmund dumm fragt
gut verträgt und zugenäht
oder wer viel fliegt der krieg ich fiele
antwort ja
[Musik]
ja herr papa
wer geiler typ 2 fahren jetzt zum
dritten mal in folge der amerikanischen
umweltbehörde den etat gekürzt was ist
denn an so was hier bitte geil aber das
ist eben ein einfacher weg um an kohle
zu gelangen
das mittelgebirge der appalachen hat
sich dadurch grundlegend verändert es
ist kein gebirge mehr
ja da brauchen sie es auch gar nicht so
vorwurfsvoll zu kommen
was glauben sie denn wie viele deutsche
auch die schnauze voll haben von diesem
ganzen grünen verbots irrsinn der uns da
aufgedrückt wird von kim jungen habeck
und seiner wirsing fraktion
nein nein nein den leuten steht es bis
hier
der deutsche sagt doch recht mich ihr
öko faschisten ich will aber an
silvester böllern bis mir vier finger
fehlen
und wenn ich bock drauf habe weiß was
dann springe ich halt einfach mal ein
ganzes mittelgebirge weg weinort der
blöde hart studie hat mich immer genervt
deshalb genau deshalb ist trump unser
idol
das macht alles total sinn ist lässt
sich nur wahnsinnig schwer steigern ich
meine was wird als nächstes machen süße
beeren erwirken
was daran nicht so lustig das haben wir
alles schon lange
was handelt das haben wir alles schon
eingetütet der chris lee ist in scharen
heilig und ausgerechnet den möchte die
trump regierung zur jagd freigegeben
vielen dank herr post bzw passt perfekt
wenn ich noch ganz kurz unser
premiumprodukt präsentieren darf das
hier ist unsere neue fair gehandelte
landmine die bam bam pufpaff 3000 leicht
zu verlegen glutenfrei und
umweltfreundlich denn sie ist aus voll
recycelbar am aluminium aluminium sind
ja it-service beweise sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus und
wieder einzuschalten hat nichts gebracht
verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung